i've watched buzzfeed medical videos
i've been in buzzfeed medical videos but
today i'm actually reacting to buzzfeed
medical videos
i played never have i ever with dr mama
jones never have i ever gotten a really
bad grade on something in medical school
who hasn't i mean med school is tough
like some of the subjects just
absolutely beat you down i don't know
why biochemistry really stopped me the
most never have i ever pulled an
all-nighter come on who hasn't pulled an
all-nighter in med school if any of them
say they have not i don't buy it i
don't believe in all nighter she's never
pulled an all-nighter that's really
impressive i will go to bed at like 10
30 every night look she knows herself
that's impressive that's a good thing
the fact that she's organized enough to
prevent that from being a problem
amazing never have i ever messed up when
learning or trying to do something
and that's what learning is about even
if you read about doing something in
practice it's a completely different
story like you learn on a mannequin you
go to see a patient and then you realize
they're a human not a mannequin and they
have their own intricacies and anatomic
anomalies it gets hard first we were
practicing intubation which is basically
you know putting a tube in someone's
mouth so they can breathe if they can't
breathe on their own and it was
mannequins obviously but
the very first thing the doctor said was
don't go like this or else you're gonna
break their teeth and the actual
mannequins have a design in them so if
you are pulling like that it makes like
a huge crunch noise to scare you and
teach you that you could be hurting
their teeth never have i ever fallen
asleep in class i remember this is such
a funny story to tell when i was in
undergrad the professor had a very
strict rule if you were going to fall
asleep in the classroom you had to sit
in the back row and rest your head
against the wall so it looks like you're
paying attention that was a legit rule
and i kind of thought like he was being
maybe sarcastic or something so one
night where i didn't get good sleep i'm
in the second to last row and i kind of
fell asleep on my arm he kicked me out
of the class and at the end of that
class there was a quiz that i then got a
zero on i really thought he was kidding
i'm not a doctor
by the way doctors aren't also good at
pronouncing these medical terms and sam
already has told me that i have to
pronounce these so be prepared for some
bad pronunciation english is my second
language bohr bergami
borberkini this is actually just like
the sound your stomach makes so like
this isn't that exciting bor borigny a
bourbon or a beginning borborygmy four
i feel like it has something to do with
the butt it's an adhd problem i'm born
with an extra of something like you got
a bad butt why is everyone talking about
butts colleedo oh this is good colito co
colito colithiasis i've actually
pronounced this term in residency
because i couldn't pronounce it colleeto
colithiasis that's how i i don't even
need to look at it because it was so
hard for me to pronounce i actually
practiced reciting this because this
means you have a gallstone
in the common bile duct call it
docolithiasis
that guy's my favorite ankylosing
spondylitis this is an easy one thank
you losing spence spandelitis and kill
losing spontaliditis
i like that they call it ankle losing
temporoperia talis but like i think this
is just like a headache you have to take
it latin so temporo means your temples
parietal is the sides all right tell us
i don't know what this is
temporopariatalis
oh it is a scalp muscle it's figmo
manometer remember dilshado couldn't get
this spig
nominometer spig nominometer it's a
sphincter manometer is that how you say
it i thought it was this big nominometer
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
the er a guy with like the thing you use
for guacamole i guess to like grind it i
know what that thing's called uh he put
that up his rectum i feel like we did
like a whole reddit thing of people
putting weird things into their bodies
mom and dr jones on the channel said
something similar the things that come
along with gynecology are endless
anything you can imagine has probably
happened what's the worst smell you've
experienced i don't know if you want to
hear this an infected gangrenous wound
by far the worst has an incident ever
freaked you out there was a guy that
came in one time and i unwrapped his
foot and there was maggots all over his
foot and it was my job lucky me to go
and clean up the maggots and the maggots
pretty much ate like down to the bone
well the maggots usually eat dead tissue
they're not feeding on live tissues that
means there's some kind of gangrene
already setting in there how often do
you have to look up a diagnosis every
day i mean things are changing all the
time
you see
a lot of the same things all the time
and then like once in a blue moon you'll
get you'll get something that like you
don't know at all i mean that's part of
medicine you just can't know everything
so yeah you're gonna look stuff up when
you look stuff up you become more
comfortable with dealing with the
unknown that's what makes medicine fun
it's like an ever learning field
do you still check web web and md when
you don't feel well absolutely first of
all everyone still checks webmd even
when you become a doctor maybe you shift
over to medscape but little did you know
webmd and medscape are the same company
do you rely on coffee to keep you going
now yes med school no every single day
there's a schedule too it's like for
three months coffee and then two week
break so that it works again that's a
true doctor he's like
cycling his caffeine intake to make sure
he's getting the maximum benefit from it
have you ever successfully diagnosed
yourself with something that's classic
med school 101. you learn a condition
you think you have the condition you
learn a condition that occurs in one per
million people that comes with a
headache you have a headache you say you
have this condition it's just normal
it's part of the process no but i have
successfully misdiagnosed myself with a
bunch of things what was your least
favorite part of medical school step one
step one step one that's the first
boards that you take uh like the
licensing exam oh you have to know so
much information so much of it being
pretty practically speaking useless oh
man that that was tough because that
decides a lot of times where you end up
in terms of your residency so like is it
true that a lot of med students
experiment with drugs
caffeine all the time caffeine yeah i
wouldn't say experiment
i feel like there's more to that story
[Music]
right from the ocean dolphin and turtle
safe
i'm not joking either
[Music]
yeah tea with honey manuka honey green
tea combo
a little lemon with the vitamin c kick
yummy
no no no get the apple cider vinegar out
of here
no it doesn't
stop that stop that nonsense right now
the honey actually works quite well for
cough the american academy of
pediatricians actually recommends this
as part of their growing body of
evidence that honey can work as well or
better than some over-the-counter cough
suppressants you have to make sure not
to give honey to kids younger than the
age of two
[Music]
this is just extra you do not need to do
this for cough suppression just let it
cough like if you have phlegm in your
lungs and you're trying to get it out
let your body get it out this is a good
thing
[Music]
drinking lots of fluids or a decent
amount of fluids when you're sick and
flemy is really good because it actually
thins the mucus and you're able to clear
it easier
oh come on this is like a commercial for
almonds this is definitely sponsored
that's like saying oh your head hurts
take a magnesium tablet come on
[Music]
i mean i just prefer going out and
shelling out the five bucks or so for
like the sailing nasal spray that's
really good because it does clear out
your sinuses you could just like spit it
back out in fact it's also really good
for allergies as well so yeah i'm for it
i just don't know like this technique
specifically
never do this you're gonna wake up with
athlete's foot because your foot has
been soaked in water it's all gonna be
all shriveled up we don't live in the
1800s anymore like you just don't need
to do this anymore
it's ridiculous
[Music]
the reason you're having a fever is to
actually improve your body's chances to
fight off whatever bug is causing you
problems so putting on cold socks is not
the solution i would never recommend
check out here for a playlist of my
craziest medical stories from the
hospital
[Music]
you